thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a pro
Semitic wild ride with Stevo we've got
Ari shafir and man is his new special
insanely good it's called Jew I watched
it I'm just raving about it it's the
most impressed I've been by a comedy
special in a long time and uh candidly I
wasn't sure about having him on the
podcast like I was like he's done some
bad things you know but uh I made a deal
with myself that I would uh
confront him about his bad things so you
can count on this episode being juicy
and it's coming to you from my tour bus
which is in Fuego right now it's
actually very cold outside but man are
my show is getting hot I did an arena an
arena like literally man I broke my
record for the biggest shows I've ever
done back to back in in two shows like
it's insane what's happening with my
bucket list tour and it's the last shows
you got your last chance to see it live
and there's only a handful of dates left
so to get on it
um also like as hard as I'm working to
try to become like a big deal you know
man you can become a big deal
with this crazy thing that's actually
saving the world it's called established
titles and what it is it's it's uh you
save the world because you're buying a
little plot of land and planting a tree
and in doing so in the Scottish
tradition of land owners being
considered Lords and Ladies you will be
responsible for planning a tree owning a
you know cubic foot maybe size plot of
land and uh that land's gonna be saved
forever for the environment because you
are the man or the lady a lord or a lady
and for doing this you get the official
title of Lord or lady and you get an
official
certificate which you can hang on the
wall to prove that you're a lord or lady
and I think you can legally change your
like title maybe your name you are our
Lord you're literally Lord or a lady and
they made the deal that if the first 200
people
if you hurry up then your plot of land
will be right next to my plot of land no
more than a couple minutes walking
distance and this is literally saving
the world man dude I'm so happy to be a
part of this and I want you to be a part
of this plus you get 10 off if you go to
established titles.com
Stevo I mean come on dude who doesn't
want to be a lord or a lady I mean be
the man take that title get that W go to
establishtitles.com
and let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen Ari shaffir gonna
try it yeah I do it that way every time
man you know my co-host Scott Randolph
indeed probably you guys met back in
2015.
what was 2015. when we did the the uh
jackass night first we did a
storytelling night no I wasn't there did
you do it for a comedy stuff we'll get
into that but I've got my first question
it's like how much [ __ ] am I gonna catch
for having you on so
so you're gonna cut off my pot stirring
for sure okay like I mean I just gotta
get right into this because because
multiple groups of people hate me the
the uh you took a lie detector test and
and passed the lie detector test saying
that you do not regret your whatever it
was a tweet or a story or something
about Kobe you got to be true to your
[ __ ] stand-up man I mean dude I see
all these people whenever some
celebrities I'm like [ __ ] wrenching
their [ __ ] clothes publicly making it
by themselves and it's always nausea
anime it's like it's like that we know
that thing with people used to do on
Facebook where it's like
you know my dad's gone 10 years ago
today I miss you we're like who the [ __ ]
are you talking to
and then this is the the new version of
that it's just like
it's just like oh I lost some celebrity
I've never met oh Michael Jackson died
I'm so sad [ __ ] you right just keep it
to yourself play a podcast it is
interesting like when like Prince died
like people can't cope and they they
won't go to work for the day yeah it
wasn't even come out with new music it
was done
yeah and so it's like I see it I just
want to mock it so I just always say
something shitty about the guys and then
most people like it and everyone then
like five percent of people are like
fine but I'm mad so you don't run
anything by a team before you say
but but in in the immediate wake of the
Kobe thing yeah like you did go pretty
quiet like a for a moment there dude
they yeah I mean I guess they were using
my wall on on Twitter to like docs my
friends and managers and [ __ ] so like
they were like on like that tweet they'd
be like hey here's his manager's address
here's her phone number go [ __ ] her up
So eventually like oh Jesus you guys are
out of control man yeah but yeah you're
classy people like your fans classy
[ __ ] people
and then uh that that all kind of like
blue
what was what was the bigger uh
catastrophe in your life the Kobe thing
or the drugging bird it oh good question
well that one was worse because my
friend wasn't like he was like he wasn't
talking to me for a while yeah so that
did bother me and his wife was just
exposing dorks yeah and this one just
yeah then burnt's wife still doesn't
talk to you yeah Brad is uh Brad and his
wife are [ __ ] he's he's president but
his wife is not it's not a fan I just
had her flowers I'll be like hey lady
I'm sorry I'll stay out of your way yeah
first of all that was the greatest
podcast in the history of podcasting all
right we took Molly and just [ __ ] had
a [ __ ] Molly I gave him Molly I gave
him free Molly dude some of the finest
[ __ ] you can find in New York and I gave
it to him no questions asked wait wait
what was it no questions
oh it was fun that was uh at Bert's
house wasn't it yeah yeah yeah he was
like uh he was from New York so you flew
with it yeah I was flying on tour I was
like I just got an idea I'm like I'm
gonna give somebody Molly on a podcast I
don't know who had transport it up my
ass really no I always like to hear how
people transport drugs you know they
ain't looking tsa's dumb they ain't
looking for that [ __ ] yeah I mean dude
to be fair it's not like a like a you
know pass out-able amount it's just like
a little bit what what I um noticed over
the years was that going through
security like like whatever they look at
whatever they saw money like they're
like oh no no you you keep your cash
like I don't want it you don't be
accused of stealing it better than a
show like The Keeping drugs in cash
money yeah which I kind of did anyway I
don't know maybe you had like Coke or
something you'd like pull it into a
dollar and like kept twisting it up how
much how much blow do you think you've
eight times
ah I didn't fly that much with like real
narcotics but but whatever the problem
with Coke is like it's always a like hey
you want you won't blow you're like yeah
okay but it's not a I I better have some
blow on me like weed you're like I I
gotta fly with some weed cause I'll need
it right I feel like I'm never gonna do
this again so it's fine I got to a point
where I needed the coke oh really yeah I
definitely needed it like I could not
fly without it well you know like Elton
John like where you woke up in the
morning and snorted blow
and then you could function no
I mean not like wake up in the morning
no I'd like uh you just do a whip it
right when you woke up yeah I mean
whatever underrated drug it's nitrous
whippets yeah okay so let's talk about
the uh the this is not happening you had
this show on on Comedy Central yeah well
first I just we just did it live like
the way you did it right okay yeah and
uh it came out it was like a Big Show in
Comedy Central yeah it was the coolest
stand-up show they ever had for sure and
at one point like in between Seasons you
guys decided let's get like like as many
of the guys from jackasses we can to
come on stage and tell crazy stories and
just kind of feel it out and test it and
see if it would be a good episode yeah
so we do theme episodes and some of the
like travel stories some of the with
this whatever uh we were thinking of
having like a Tracy Morgan storytelling
show I'll probably do like just
everybody tells the difference there's
so many Tracy Morgan stories that I'm
like I could get four or five Comics
episode will be so huge for sure I
thought about it for sure is identical
yeah
he got like hundreds of people telling
precisely the same story Bad episode
Comedy Festival we'll get back to but
he's thrown out of a bar at like 2PM and
we're like any dick and he just throws
some he just takes some of those uh root
beer candies you know whatever
who the [ __ ] is this fairy guy yeah yeah
so um so themed episodes and then it was
gonna be uh yeah jackass and we were
like let's yeah I don't know if we
reached out to you first or whatever but
everybody was down it was um everybody
was down I think everybody had a had a
blast and that was the first time for uh
all the other guys to ever get on the
stage yeah oh yeah I remember that
because you were like people don't
realize if I could take some some work
to do stand up yeah and you had this
experience now so you were like hey guys
I actually like you could just tell like
I know what I'm doing with this
microphone
right I mean distinctly the the trial
did not
um succeed because there was never a
jackass themed episode I think we I
think I lost the show pretty shortly
after that okay I wonder when it was
that was 2015. it was 2015. yeah well it
wasn't that short after that
yeah that's still like a thing we wanted
to do I'm very interested in hearing uh
about the the losing of the show what
would like as I understood it you
recorded a special for Comedy Central
not just for myself for yourself and
then like it was going to be on Comedy
Central but you pulled it and moved it
somewhere else in that episode yeah I
upset well it's that's not it's it's I
got sick of taking notes from people on
my stand-up
um from like just some guy wearing a
suit like ah like I'll just do what I
want to do and I'm sure you get it all
the time we're like maybe you shouldn't
do this you're like yeah I want to
choose my own show right like a live
show like I don't want you telling me
what I should do right thanks with the
input yeah maybe but you know I'll do
what I want right so at some point I was
like I'm just gonna make this myself and
figure it out and pay for it it was kind
of one of the early ones of doing that
and then I made it and then they made me
an offer and I was like
um I didn't take the offer right and
then I went to I just took off went to
Southeast Asia for a few months just for
fun you know I was like finished with
the season of the show yeah what do you
do for fun in Southeast Asia that sounds
so creepy
[ __ ] boys dude young boys where'd you go
uh I started at Myanmar just because
like I waited till like a day before and
I was like where's the weather the best
and there was like no rain in the
Myanmar forecast so I went there first
and then uh I called an Uber then I
threw my phone in the drawer and I just
[ __ ] went to the airport with no
phone I locked myself out of all my
accounts wow I like changed my passwords
like to just slam me on the keyboard
gave those to my friends and I'm like
don't don't give them to me so I
couldn't get on any like social media my
email I had no phone did you regret that
term no was it like a are you kidding
nobody's bothering me no no
responsibility right it was the greatest
what what what prompted this
I just wanted to travel yeah yeah and
Comedy Central was up my ass like no we
gotta do another show
come on we gotta do a season and I'm
like God I did it all right like you're
going right back in it's eight months of
editing to get everybody's story right
and then uh and then my buddy Duncan
Trussell he was just like well you want
to travel and see the world and they
want you to not travel to see the world
so like what's the question even yeah
right oh yeah you're right and so I was
like hey I'm out
um did you come back with any epiphanies
because I know like when I travel I'll
go for a month and then then you realize
that's what you really want yeah you
start seeing real clearly all the
[ __ ] chaff and your brain drops off
and you're just like what am I what do I
care about what do I like
um do you feel like you upped your game
when you came back on that trip what do
you make up my game just kind of like uh
you realize what was important and you
just went [ __ ] straight for it like
did you get more successful after that
or were you've always been kind of on us
personally successful like not you're
there's like you're talking about
Creative Financial or like personal what
success is you know personal yeah for
sure like I went after what I wanted all
the time it was like this is all about
like what I'm trying to put out none of
this I'm already making money enough to
pay my rent yeah so like this is all
bonus people get lost in it for sure
people get lost trying to keep up with
their friends instead of like you're all
just we're all just writing dick jokes
and we're we're paying our rents
did you do any psychedelics in Southeast
Asia
found mushrooms one one time on lombok
in Indonesia that was pretty [ __ ]
chill because I feel like in Myanmar
don't they have those the the honey that
people go and try to get from the bees
that's psychedelic honey oh yeah I
didn't get any of that I just stayed in
hostels I was a nobody it was [ __ ] it
was it was Bob yeah it was just like
yeah nobody recognized nobody wanted
anything out of me it was just like such
Freedom like I think I'll go from this
city to this city and people like I
heard there's a [ __ ] Tomato Festival
over here like all right I'll change my
plan yeah and you just there was nowhere
to go
there was no you had to be it was great
the toilets took some getting used to
but like the the toilets in the ground
yeah bum guns no no flushing of toilet
paper and what a great opportunity that
would be to promote Squatty Potty oh
absolutely
Stevo's butt wipes available right now
at stevo.com that's exactly where
they're available not only will they get
your butt squeaky clean but you're also
supporting one of the finest stuntman
comedians in the country Steve-O that's
for you
I dude don't make it look difficult
because
he loves wet wipes
they're butt wipes for your butthole
please
yeah let's see what we'll see what it
comes out as a little bit Brown
before that's uh especially after a
skank Fest weekend
[Laughter]
yeah dude
um oh anyway so I got back so I got back
and I was like let me so Netflix is only
doing celebrities at the time when I
when I was like first pitching my
special but then I'm like four or five
months passed and I'm like let me see
what they're up to I think they're
taking like regular people now
um they totally revamped and like I'm
Chappelle and only like you know 20
million dollar people and now they're
like well we are actually like giving
seven seconds don't you have a deal with
Comedy Central I'm like no they have an
offer but no
and um nobody's watching comedy central
[ __ ] anymore it was like on its way way
down and then they were like all right
we'll give you an offer and then Comedy
Central was like
uh-uh right and they were like here's
the deal you got to do with us I'm like
no you guys don't have the reach plus it
was like a two-part special and they had
a platform to
to show two parts of anything right I
was like HBO wouldn't have the platform
either you just can't show it
and they said you have to and they said
if you don't they were like they're
contracted for 10 episodes but they were
gonna do 20 so I get them all at once if
you don't we have to do 10 but we're
cutting you from 20 to 10 we're going to
fire all your employees who put them out
of work with a weak to spare good luck
paying their rent
um or you can walk away they appealed to
the compassion in you for others what a
bad mistake
I was like [ __ ] I was first of all well
played well played and then I was like
but I'm not going to comply right so now
you were like yeah you you said good
luck to my employees and I'm with you
good luck to them yeah I'm going to
Netflix you're like I was gonna do that
anyway yeah so they found someone else
and kept the 20 episodes that was a
thing I should have been like I should
have played Hardball I should have been
like then do it then do it right and all
the employees later were like what do
you mean that's part of it I'm like
[ __ ] what do you mean that shows
shows you know stop a week or two out
it's still a 10 episodes still be a week
of work right but they just kind of
blackmailed me yeah so and so we're um
having these you had some special on
Netflix the two parts it was great and
and at that time like that being having
a special on Netflix like just
revolutionized your touring yeah yeah it
got big I was the mayor of New York for
like two weeks Netflix ain't that thing
anymore but at the time it was I mean
everywhere I went I could take those
City bikes around people like oh my God
I sounded special it was like everywhere
it was [ __ ] wild it has a reach that
my the show and the special like The
Comedy Central just didn't have right
um
you know right now we're promoting your
newest special and where is that
youtube.com there we go I didn't even
[ __ ] pitch it to Netflix right oh you
didn't oh I didn't even show it to him
how come they don't have a reach anymore
they put up too much stuff it's like
they come and go YouTube has the reach
now and it's cooler you hear that and
now it's like that's a corporation
you're not independent anymore no it's
still fine it's still a place to watch
some good [ __ ] but like right I want
people to see my thing I worked hard on
it you know okay it's all about Judaism
but it's just funny [ __ ] so I was like I
want people to see it
so I'm out a lot of money
I'm not going to get back but whatever
it's more to life man it's interesting
because uh I wanted to have my special
on Netflix so bad yeah and uh the guy in
charge of the specials yeah just he's
like um you know Stevo stand up like
like we he's like a comedy snob he's
like you can't I'm not gonna do a Stevo
special and uh it broke my heart but you
know I was like whenever I put it out on
my own I didn't put it on YouTube what'd
you do I put it on my website with the
paywall stevo.com yeah it's not a place
where you can get Steve's butt wipes
yeah
okay
and uh it works out really well like uh
I I you know if I tripled the money that
I put into it yeah and um but that the
thing was though
I felt that I was kind of preaching to
the choir like the people who are going
to go to stevo.com and pay for it on the
paywall like yeah I wasn't brought I
felt like if I got it on Netflix that I
would be reaching a new audience that's
what you want convert it would be like a
commercial for my tour yeah people do
that with Louie did his special he did
the first one like five dollars and he
made like a million bucks like in a week
or something it was like what and then
Gaffigan and Rogan tried to do the same
thing and it wasn't it wasn't like the
they didn't get as much because it
wasn't the first time anybody did that
right with Louie he was like wait what
we can just own someone special right
but then Louis turned around did it
again and it was even when he was
promoting on Saturday Night Live oh yeah
but but yeah he did it well but the
other guys I heard gaffigans his problem
was he was like it's preaching the choir
so I'm selling to my fans so I didn't
grow my fan base at all and I just want
new people to see it people that are
like hey I don't mind I have 30 bucks to
go see your show but I've heard about
you let me let me give them an hour plus
to like right watch what you put out and
then they just they'll love it you know
I worked hard on it right so that's
funny as [ __ ] so like you'll love it go
go to YouTube go find it is it uh
trademark just like terribly offensive
crap I don't even think that way anymore
I don't know if you get like that is
this offensive like oh um let me think
in those terms I don't know yeah it's
almost like were you standing knowing
that I'm like um
yeah yeah I was like I might be thinking
about that is there a lot of blue shirts
in this you're like oh I don't know I
mean I I just said kind of like when I
think of Arya shapir I think of like
deliberately being offensive like for
the dude no it's not for the [ __ ]
it's funny it's for the fun but dude if
I'm not getting a couple of people
walking out angry at my shows I'm not
doing my job I had some people leaving
some [ __ ] Pro school shooting jokes
you know in Chicago and these people
were like old people like my daughters
told me to come watch this and it's not
just it's not just that it's offensive
it's in everyone else is laughing yeah
are there school shooting jokes on the
news special
there's some Holocaust jokes there's
some um let me think no the next one
after this I'll have a good nice school
shooting chunk
I hate kids I'm fine with them I was
telling Shane Gillis about
um this uh comedian Sophie bottle that I
worked with I've known it for years
great school shooting joke she just said
like it's just not worth it to be a
bully anymore
album baby skeletons it was like quick
when uh Parkland happened and it was
happening on Ash Wednesday and she goes
it was even worse because like all those
kids had Targets on their heads oh my
god dude you told that the night after
it happened and everyone was like
and then this eruption of laughter went
off and I'm like you gotta take some
chances
yeah I I personally don't like offending
people I don't want to offend people I
want people who are cool to be like oh
right but like you got to get on that
line which means some dorks are gonna be
over the line dude I'll tell you this
this uh gnarly joke
yeah so you know what's [ __ ] gnarly
like I was getting ready to do the
Charlie Sheen roast
oh boy why did I tell this story I'm
really not proud of what I admit here
but it's gonna be juicy so get ready to
be really entertained but God I wish I
would have just trimmed it out of this
episode too late now but it's not too
late for you to trim all kinds of
unwanted disgusting body hair out of
your bush your nose your ears and man is
it a good time of year to jump on board
Thanksgiving man be thankful for
manscapes PP
4.0 the performance package dude they
load it all into this baby you got the
lawnmower 4.0 you got the weed whacker
for the nose and the ears you got the
the ball
deodorant the the ball retriever I mean
dude they got more ball products than I
can keep track of and they're all
awesome plus it comes with a travel
package to keep it all in I mean dude
you are on top of your game ready for
the ladies all right ladies you're ready
for the men I mean dude nobody wants to
see a disgusting Bush and they damn well
don't want to see all the nose hairs
so jump on the performance package 4.0
by going to manscapes.com
Stevo and you not only do you get 20 off
your order
they give you free shipping too it's
insane man manscapes.com get the
performance package 4.0
20 off your order plus free shipping by
going to manscapes.com
steva now oh God I'm about to
um yeah I forgot how you're on that yeah
Mike Tyson Pancho yeah I ran into Mike
Tyson's fist
he sends me this joke he's like dude
look at the Deus and say who are these
people the last time this many nobodies
got roasted at least great white was
playing nice you don't know that was a
[ __ ] fired a great white concert a
bunch of people died but a lot of those
people were losers
I mean there's more to the story
well here's here's what happened yeah
like I mean I heard that I I that's a
roast you're supposed to be of everyone
signing up for it understood by all the
people in Rhode Island where the fire
happened didn't sign up for it you know
and the arsonist did
Mike but I mean yeah okay so so I tell
Jeffy Ross I'm like I'm like man dad
tell him the joke and and Jeffrey goes I
guarantee you he loved it he says oh my
God you have to use that joke on the
roast oh my God you have to I'm like
dude I would never say anything this is
offensive and he's like oh my God you
have to so we go around like the LA
clubs like practicing like uh our our
roast sets yeah and every I'm like I'm
like whatever I'm at the The Comedy
Store like I'll just throw it out there
and it was like the biggest laugh out of
the whole deal and I started to think
myself oh my God like that joke is kind
of killing like maybe like uh yeah maybe
I'll use it so on at the you know they
taped the roast like a couple days
before or where do they tape it and then
it takes them like a week or so to put
it out yeah you know all the bombs yeah
so uh I'm sorry I said it at the taping
you know I said the the great white joke
and um
the next morning after the taping like
my whole Facebook feed like it's just
people like you know it goes burning
hell yeah like hey and I'm like dude I'm
like why do they get it I'm like I'm
like did the roach didn't even come out
yet and what it was
was that there was a writer from
Entertainment Weekly who was present at
the taping sure he was not cool and and
he he uh he wrote up a thing about that
he was at the taping right and he just
wrote up like some examples of jokes
that he included in like a Blog oh he
didn't even [ __ ] on it
he just included it as a list of jokes
that just examples of what was said at
the roast and like somebody in Rhode
Island uh saw the this blog and like
what like was offended and then posed it
was like this viral thing and like
everybody in Rhode Island was so mad at
me and upset like and I'd never been in
that kind of situation because I'm just
not someone who seeks to like be
offensive and hurt people's feelings
like it it affected me so badly I got on
with with Jeffrey Ross with Comedy
Central I'm like I'm on my knees begging
me begging you please please cut that
joke out please cut that
and uh like I issued an apology like the
whole deal and I swear I was it's just
like I get you know I want to defend
people but it's not for them whoever
showed it to them was an [ __ ] you
know it's not for those people why would
you show somebody it's like taking
Minecraft to a [ __ ] Jewish school I'd
be like do you see this you're like
don't show them that right you're not
supposed to see it right well
I don't know I I wanna I wanna this is
the problem is it's everything's
worldwide now so if you go to a comedy
club everyone there is like we're in
this dark hole we want to hear these
really dark evil things and that boy
signed up for it's a contract right and
then you show you tell somebody where
you get on their phone and then yeah
it's not for them yeah it's like why
would you why would you bother them
right some some uh or like you know you
talk [ __ ] with your friend about
somebody about another friend and then
somebody will go tell that friend and
you're like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you right that's behind the scenes trash
talk yeah that guy's not supposed to
know about that and it's like why'd you
say that I'm like no no why did I tell
you he's like you know like when you
talk [ __ ] about your friend to Bird
yeah I didn't say that but it was behind
your back dude it's all good
dude you should have said how many times
Bert said I love you during that but I
guess
first time doing Molly just rubbing your
leg he was loving it now his cat sat
down on the couch next to him and he was
like he's just staring at this cat just
before he realized it no after he
realized Audrey realized it and um and
then after he got comedian of the year
or something so maybe you're responsible
for that I'm for sure responsible for it
I left this game I helped him see
clearly right and he said his cat's
looking at him he's dude my cat sees me
and I was like yeah I know he goes you
don't know my cat sees me
I'm like yeah feeling bro and you guys
never aired that he never heard it I
gave him a cash 22. I gave him the best
podcast of 2019. and he oh on the
podcast he was like I am pissed but also
I get that you know I love good content
so you gave me an amazing podcast Joy
Diaz came over telling the story
watching the sunset behind him we're
both like it was awesome and the
question is if you put that podcast
behind a paywall would it do better than
who makes 74 million dollars for sure
yeah it would do better than my special
orange if you're Drew available now for
free uh would do it it would do better
than anything I say Bert released the
pot it's been long enough yeah yeah I
have Eric shaffir Jew it's just called
yeah it's a theme hour I've never really
done one like that like that hard before
I was Orthodox Jewish I was [ __ ] wow
you were studying scripts I was reading
that about you you went to college and
you studied the Jewish scripture I went
to Seminary I was going to be a rabbi
hard turn when uh did you back out of
that what did you make that turn it's
41st trip 21 years old yeah I got I got
a [ __ ] BJ and it was like uh is this
allowed and they were like hard no
yeah
I want the bacon route
that's crazy what do you do about
paintball at your shows recording videos
cell phones I hate it for that reason
right it's like you're taking this to
people who aren't supposed to see it
well right and you might be taking
material before it's ready so that used
to be the problem was like you're gonna
put this up and it's not done yet right
and and it's like people don't it's like
the state you know what the stand-up
process is tweaking while you're
performing it yeah so you're showing a a
finished product that's also not
finished right it's finished when I'll
record it and put it up right and even
if it if it is polished and finished and
ready then that's up to you you're
taking my [ __ ] yeah yeah it's like
taking a manuscript for some guy wrote a
book like I'll just release it right
you're like no no no
so I don't like it but also it makes
people not pay attention I see them like
on their phones or like I'm like let's
just listen to my [ __ ] setup dude
right I'm [ __ ] you know I'm telling a
joke you're missing the setup you're
just coming at the end going like what
the [ __ ] here's my favorite thing I do
when I see people like on their phones
during a show I do if you're in a
stand-up comedy show from an audience
perspective I exciting that's a fun
night on a date or whatever and you're
missing it so you can [ __ ] scroll
Instagram or some [ __ ] so like as I'm
talking I'll take I'll take a napkin off
someone's table I'm at a club and then
I'll like uh wad it up and I'll see over
there and I'll just like like really
like Telegraph it and they're dead their
heads down and I'll just like hit them
in the head with a napkin they go like
you're like what the [ __ ] I'm like you
weren't paying attention I guess I was
I'm like what was I talking about and
then they're like
um I don't know where are you paid for
tickets
yeah what do you do I mean you could
bring back the the Yonder bags yeah no
one can they can't trust themselves
anymore we're all such addicts right
don't do it then you get a buzz in your
phone you're like let me see your text
and like oh well I'm out I may as well
record this I mean even if they're out
of service they can still record a video
yeah they can so it's like just yeah
your honor bags help it's almost like we
I when you're on the back started people
like what the [ __ ] and now they're like
I get it
that was the best part about southeast
Asia there was no I wasn't on there I
wasn't on there was no reason to record
anything
I had a camera if I really wanted to
take a picture of some people I met and
but that's it it was just like it's
you're free of it yeah dude you're on
there too much aren't you oh way too
much yeah you too right 100 I got off
social media for like a couple years
okay I just got back on because I put a
documentary out there [ __ ] hooks in
yeah yeah you need it for this one
um I uh at my show is multimedia so like
I did all this [ __ ] up stuff you know
and tell the stories of it and then
after each bit I paid off with the
footage of the bit oh that's cool yes so
I have cool thank you I have the luxury
of having a screen and video anyways so
I've got like an intro video where I'd
say like you know you're gonna see I put
a lot of work into this show and you're
not invited to steal it so please don't
yeah and that's I find pretty effective
really yeah he caught somebody recording
I think that people should know when
they go to a comedy show not to record
with their phone that's stealing man and
boy wait to hear what I did to this
person that I caught and frankly
numerous people I just don't like it man
I mean don't be putting out my comedy
special before I get the chance to and
I'm actually filming my special in all
kinds of different cities so if you're
going to one of these remaining dates
then you have a chance of being in my
special it's the [ __ ] [ __ ] man and
speaking of [ __ ] I think I've told you
that my favorite uh product that I've
ever promoted on this podcast I'm
standing by it is my bidet from
hellotushy.com you know I uh it kills me
that I don't have it on the tour bus I
just I don't think you can have it on
the tour bus man and it's that's the one
thing I don't love about my tour bus
hello
tushy.com has is the greatest products
man it's if you don't know what a bidet
is you sit down on there and you twist
this little knob and this nozzle goes
Boop and just perfectly blasts your
butthole fresh and clean you can
slightly move around adjust it to just
get it right on there it's refreshing
it's clean it saves the environment
because you're cutting down uh 80
percent on your use of toilet paper your
buttholes perfectly clean like man and
they've got all these great products
plus if you go to hellotushy.com Stevo
it's 10 off your order and free shipping
and look I've never said another product
was my favorite except for hello tushy
that's probably pretty reckless of me
but I don't care I love them that much
and if you haven't tried it you're gonna
love them that much too so get on over
to hellotushy.com Stevo 10 off your
order plus free shipping your butthole
is gonna love it now let's get back to
it
this has happened a bunch of times most
of the time by the way when they're
filming they just want to be able to
show their friends not send it to
anybody like look I was at a Steve show
yeah but Steve jumped off you don't know
yeah he [ __ ] grabbed that happened a
bunch of times you've jumped off stage
you jumped off the stage while
performing grabbed the person's phone
they followed me out and then these like
delete it and then then show me your
delete box and then delete it again and
that happens how often does that happen
I mean it doesn't happen a lot but I'm
just protective yeah out of it because
then I'm looking around the room and
sometimes like I'm just taking a picture
I'm like I don't know that now I'm
thinking like what am I saying because
sometimes I'm saying well maybe not
offensive stuff but like stuff that's
like this shouldn't be out there this is
just for the live experience there's
another time years ago when we were it
was 2014 we were in New Zealand and uh
some this is and I didn't blow a load in
the entire year of 2014. you're a
[ __ ] loser idiot he went 430
something days without blowing a loaded
exotic rehab
so I'm I'm in the celibacy period I'm
flipping my life not I didn't blow alone
for the whole time celibate and uh
during that period we were in New
Zealand and that's some chick was
filming
and I like berated or I went off
and uh there was like a a prince
journalist in the crowd who just wrote
this story about what a terrible [ __ ]
I was and I was like if I just let the
chick record like nobody would have seen
it but now this story story comes out
with like in a proper Outlet yeah it's
not right though it didn't have to be
that hard on her yeah there is a point
in time because I'd be like backstage in
the green room and you just hear the mic
drop and just go boom it'd be done it'd
just be somebody talking and it's just
and I'd like run out to see it he's just
like but you just shut the [ __ ] up and
they're just like having a conversation
you know just a little conversation but
like he was so on edge from not blowing
a load and it just was happening wow
that and like that the heckling and the
table talk and the video recording like
it all just like builds up and
accumulates and it gets to a point where
you're just like ah I can't take it
anymore you ever seen Nina Simone
yeah like a singer but she was like she
was like it's my show you better be
[ __ ] respect that was your Vibe and
she's starting to play the piano there's
videos this and someone will just like
God and she'll just stop him
[Music]
for sure
and then go back and people were scared
of her wow
I uh it's like Steve when you like air
footage and you show people and somebody
says something he'll stop and he'll be
like and then he'll rewind it to where
they started talking you play it again
dude how was your load on the 440th yeah
it was it was underwhelming right it's
not it didn't save up you just stopped
producing yeah yeah it was underwhelming
it didn't even feel that great and it
wasn't like that huge was your load in
your hand or was it landed on my tummy
and I took a picture of it and sent it
to everybody
yeah I wonder like on on PornHub like if
it said like you know 432 day load like
that would crush you know right for sure
I would click on that you could have
sold that load
nft load yeah yeah have you sold any
nfts no yeah I tried selling a podcast
once that someone was like they were
looking into it like try it and I was
like okay and it got like no offers even
why would I want somebody want to own a
podcast right I don't want to do mine
right I don't [ __ ] own one yeah
that's where you're not gonna do crypto
I sold one nft what was it of there was
a photo of my girl and I naked like uh
simulating sex in a window
like on 20 floors above Vancouver
simulating you guys weren't even boating
we were not burning in that photo boo
I always thought you guys were boning
not we were not boning in that photo
someone took it some somebody took it
down there no we had uh like they like
there's a setting on a GoPro camera you
say GoPro take picture it takes a
picture
that's cool yeah so did anything crazy
happen this weekend at skank Fest or uh
through two weeks ago sorry two weeks
ago no I wasn't drinking I took the
month off oh yeah that's right yeah
um so it's a it's the wrong time to do
it this is a drinking town and a
drinking Festival even walk through the
hallways at the [ __ ] wherever they're
putting me up it's like God damn it
wow so during summer October if you just
slip and you're like I can't do it you
break down and have a drink is anyone
gonna know so there was one moment where
it was No No One's Gonna Know It's Just
honor you know it's just like you know
you have honor
in some ways definitely not it's a weird
set of Honor
um yeah well you know when you lose a
bet when you got to do some [ __ ] for
Jackass or whatever like you just have
to do it that's right the deal
I'm not going to but it's like that's
lame you know it's the funniest thing
about sober October is that when it
comes up yeah
like my first thought like I was like I
was shopping for a whole month and I
think [ __ ] man that's gnarly you know I
like this and then I'm like oh yeah like
I'm sober all the time yeah it's like it
makes me uncomfortable like sober
performance
because you're thinking of old Steve
yeah
it's weird and it continues to happen
you don't mess with the whoop strap at
all I no I did once it was cool we have
to do this polo shirt whatever they
chose to like yeah we do 500 the
calories a day you're going to burn
which I also hate and 100 push-ups but I
physically cannot do I'm like maxed out
at five on day one I was like hey guys I
think I'm in trouble here by the end of
the month like I did yeah I'm getting
better but like uh so anyway I was doing
Rogue because I was hanging out with
Rogan he goes I just interviewed Roger
Waters like two days ago I was like
that's so [ __ ] badass and uh I saw
him once on acid in Rhode Island
actually uh and it was such a [ __ ]
good concert after they opened for Great
White after they opened great ride they
really took off the gray white was no
longer a threat to the dominance of
Rhode Island
um and uh you guys making me in it like
[ __ ] well you know Roger wants to do
pyrotechnics so um these aren't the
lasers so he was like I got tickets to a
show tomorrow or tonight and I'm like oh
I can't go I gotta flight back and he's
like well I'm I have a [ __ ] 700 000
billion dollars so like I'll just change
your flight for you and I'm like oh well
I have no Hotel it's the same same
and I'm like no I got to get home it's
like aren't you account I'm like yep I
gotta stay so I'm gonna see Roger Waters
but I'm sober and I'm like no it's
disrespectful
to go see Roger Waters sober it's
disrespectful and so I asked the other
guys and I was like is there something I
could do to make up for this
I just want to take one tab of acid
I won't couple it with alcohol and weed
I'll be strong
and they were like add a hundred sit-ups
a day to like your [ __ ] regimen and
you can and I view it as a [ __ ]
religious
religious like uh what is it like uh you
know you're allowed to do something for
yeah holy Scrolls
what if the acid like was wasn't great
it'd be disappointing yeah it was
stronger than I thought it would be yeah
it was stronger than I thought of it the
guy got I got it and it was like he was
like I just dip this right now so like
dry it out so I'm like holding in the
car over there I'm holding it open this
bag it opened in the air conditioner
vent of a [ __ ] car just like trying
to dry it out I was with Hinchcliffe too
and I was like uh and the only other
person that took it Rogan was like I
want to [ __ ] touch that street ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] you and I'm like you're wrong
um and the only person that took it the
only one that was a man was Tony
hinchcliffe's uh girlfriend she was
saying it's the [ __ ] post out and we
had a blast it was so [ __ ] strong
there's an intermission we went
backstage and all of a sudden it's like
regular people and we're like nah we
shouldn't be here for this so I went
back up and they were like Rogan and all
his bodyguards like hey man we're
leaving like before the last song this
is like a cavalcade to get us out you
got to be on that thing and I was like
I'm not gonna I'm out gonna be I mean
I'm crying in the [ __ ] in this in the
crowd next to some 80 year old lady ball
it crying oh what a good [ __ ] show
you guys gotta go see Roger Waters on
acid yeah it would have been a good show
not on acid sure yeah absolutely inch
cliff and Rogan had a good time yeah I
feel like the acid in the 90s was a lot
stronger than the acid they're making
now is that not true definitely can't be
true because people are not overdosing
and [ __ ] going on Hikes now I don't
microdose but like I didn't know about
microdosing in the 90s it just took a
[ __ ] hit acid like a man
but they're like seeing [ __ ] things
dripping off
like now they're like doing yoga on acid
it's like how how is that possible do I
have that wrong
I I tripped balls in the 90s yeah can
you imagine tripping balls now I think
it was unregulated then so you didn't
know you might get some you might get
the equivalent of like four hits acid
I'm pretty sure the acid is still not
regulated good point Street ass yeah
yeah but they do that they have like a
number 200 somethings and I'm like yeah
[ __ ] but this was not that but who's
saying that who's saying it exactly
you're just taking somebody's word for
it I was in a festival we had Bonnaroo
got canceled with an RV like this and we
were loading up our [ __ ] RV with
groceries for Bonnaroo and I got a call
like it ain't happening and it wasn't
covered it was it was raining and I was
like it's nice out like it rang for the
last six days the water's up to their
knees it's done it's done they're not
like delaying it it's over
I'm like [ __ ] and so we found this like
meth Festival I call it in like Western
Georgia like we still got some RV spots
and I'm like I'm going to that so we
just went there
we're buying drugs and this this uh what
kind of drugs you buying so this this RV
next to us was also supposed to be at
Bonnaroo and they were like they had
testers which is important kids do drugs
but test that [ __ ] for like fentanyl
yeah yeah
um and so somebody was like we got Coke
which is not really my drug I've done it
a few times but it's not my thing but
like so they were like hey the coke from
that guy is 100 pure Coke so like sweet
um and then they went and bought some
acid like hey they asked from that lady
is 100 not acid that is some sort of
mesclan and it's dry and my buddy was
like [ __ ] it's my [ __ ] hands and then
he starts [ __ ] going for like are you
gonna be okay because ah yeah yeah yeah
and then we're like how are you doing
it's guys I've done drugs before
okay it wasn't the plan tonight but I'll
be fine I'm at a festival
oh man that was Great Valley Vibes
greatest Festival in the [ __ ] in the
country that who's playing it nobody
nice yeah they said three stages they're
like cool the stages like this table was
one it was just a bunch of [ __ ] milk
cartons set up it was cool Carolina
story that was one band they were cool
it was a Michigan country and [ __ ] uh
um like surf metal
yeah it was bomb tons of fire ants
yeah you ever been into the k-hole
no I've done ketamine but never I wanna
have you never you yeah I [ __ ] love K
holes I mean I don't even know that okay
holes I mean I don't even necessarily
know what a k-hole is I just know that
I've had a lot of [ __ ] crazy
experience where you can't move
or like time stops I don't know about
that I can't move I remember at one
point like looking at my feet and they
were like so far away
I remember I remember another time I was
in a hotel room and the hotel room
started Free Falling like I was like
looked up and I could like see a shaft
there that the whole room was falling
through they're just falling down yeah
it was just like dude I'm [ __ ] Free
Falling in a hotel room it was it was
Stephen
I mean [ __ ] like that was just like this
is the best night of my life and like as
a sober guy like nothing's more
important to me than being clean and
sober yeah but still that was the best
night of my life
he'll be like you shouldn't have dose me
but like that was fun we're on stage of
the night people like what's up Molly
funny goes yeah
yeah I do get triggered at all hearing
people talk about drugs an equally valid
question would be am I triggered by the
thumbnail of this episode
and uh the answer is no man
um I I like to take care of my spiritual
Fitness and my physical fitness
um by just being a healthier guy and to
do that I use athletic greens I mean I'm
telling you athletic greens they're ag1
product is the most convenient
comprehensive daily nutrition period
nothing messes with it plus it's still
it's delicious you start your morning
with it you dump a scoop into the a pint
of water so that you're hydrated and
you've got all the nutrition that you
need in that pint of water to fill all
the gaps in your diet all the greens all
everything's in there it's 75 have
different whole food sourced vitamins
minerals superfoods like it's just
unbelievably packed with stuff that's
good for your gut for your brain for
like for everything it makes you think
better it makes you
did better I love it athletic greens and
it's delicious so man if you're thinking
to yourself I could be eating a
healthier diet you need it if you're
thinking about to yourself man I'm like
my memory you need it if you're you're
gut if you're worried about your gut you
need it I mean it's just the best stuff
out there and if you go to
athleticgreens.com Stevo they're going
to give you five free travel packs with
your comprehensive convenient daily
nutrition for the day five of them plus
an entire year's supply of immune
boosting vitamin D that's the deal for
the Wild Ride listeners if you go to
athleticgreens.com slash Stevo you get
that with your first order and if you
haven't tried it then figure it out get
over there athleticgreens.com Stevo now
let's get back to it
I mean are you safe in your sobriety I
weed sounds like I'm sober too and like
we the smell of weed I'm like I don't
like being around weed because I like
the smell of it too plus like there's
like uh it entering my body when I'm
breathing it in like there's kind of
like secondhand High [ __ ] I don't want
to fight true true you can't if you're
around Coke it ain't gonna get in you
right alcohol drink all the alcohol you
want around me
um but yeah I feel pretty good about it
you just don't ever want to be I would
never want to say I'm safe in my
sobriety or even I feel safe in my
sobriety like because by definition
none of us are safe in our sobriety we
gotta like stay on top of like yeah but
you know what I'm talking about though
right yeah some guys like day to day
guys other people like oh I don't really
think about it I don't think about
actually going to get loaded too much
now I I I'm more triggered on the sex
stuff because like I work a sex program
too like that that's a whole other ball
game where it's like
not drinking booze like that's minor
like trying to [ __ ] stay within some
guard rails of like sexual sobriety like
that's a little tougher
sexual sobriety yeah somebody's throwing
it at you yeah and then you're like my
body wants it yeah and then it's like
okay cool what's healthy it's like yeah
you can have some sex and then it's like
well I didn't use it I didn't use a
rubber nice and then you're like [ __ ] oh
yeah I just feel like worried for the
next that's the whole point of ease and
then you're like you gotta then you got
to keep in touch with the girl so she
until her next period
so you're sure but yeah so it's just
like thing you know that that's more on
the Forefront of my mind than like
drinking a Coors Light who says rubber
what are you born in the [ __ ] 40s why
what do they call it prophylactic no not
even early what are you a nerd a rubber
guys
you gotta check uh sometimes you know a
bang
so sometimes meaning one chick sometimes
or yeah no I've had chicks before but no
no no you ever want to get married or no
nah never no I'm not married no kids no
kids I got a vasectomy me too dude yeah
it's easy right yeah well not the way I
did it
don't go wrong I have a show tonight if
you want to you have a story about it
yeah that's one of the the Marquee bits
I got one too the vasectomy Olympics
I do want to know what that means yeah
like the the idea was born when I heard
a joke when I was a kid what's uh the
definition of Macho okay a man who jogs
home from his own vasectomy
and I was like well I want to be macho
like uh I'll do way more than [ __ ]
jog so I came up with an idea like to
just do a bunch of hellacious [ __ ]
immediately after getting a vasectomy oh
dude
you're the only one like you
kind of I mean you see pain as an
opportunity not like okay I need to take
it easy you're like oh sweet this will
be hurtful which will be nice for me
yeah and I don't have like a threshold
for pain or anything just my desire for
attention outweighs my need for
comfortably might be the worst one yeah
you saw that he was up in the car
suspended spent sleeping over there we
haven't really talked about that on the
podcast at all but were you tripping
were you like [ __ ] last night
did you start the car no wasn't it hot
it's Vegas is it hot it's a Tesla uh I
had the windows down okay yeah still
it's hot it's like 70 at night here yeah
yeah but were you like uh the sun comes
up you're [ __ ] you didn't sleep well
it got hot in the morning would you lean
your seat back
no no that this the back seats can fall
forward and then I got a special Tesla
mattress
so I have a full bed in there
a special like quart jug urinal with the
hose and a thing that comes out from
underneath you gotta sell those on
stevo.com yeah yeah not not a bad idea
did you jerk off at all in there not
that night I would have
I would have piss out the window and
jerked off
I got in big trouble uh
I I uh upset a cop a lot because uh in
the morning there's like a big crowd
underneath and uh and I'm standing up on
the you know on the roof of the car
pissing off
uh you know pissing all the way down in
the car because there are little kids
down there I mean they were over 100
feet away
[Music]
Spotify rolls are too strict
right I uh I I found myself thinking
about if I do get arrested when I come
down yeah then
yeah uh like that's kind of a cool
arrest like pissing off of a roof of a
car at 100 feet in the air
and that would be worth it I think so
yeah for sure
I I think so yeah you're on private
property right I think you're good I was
on private property what property the
UFC headquarters
did they let you they let me do it it's
the coolest guy in the world Dana White
is the coolest guy I've been talking
once we were just got Duncan Trussell as
a comic love dude my favorite episode of
this podcast my two favorites were Kevin
Smith and Duncan Trussell really yeah
interesting talking about God yeah
talking about I saw Duncan at that at
that concert and I hadn't seen him Roger
Waters yeah he's one of my best friends
we started the comic store together like
literally employees together at the
conference beginning Comics oldest
friend in Hollywood cool man I really
like him a lot it's so unique and
interesting yeah
actually this does not go with my Brink
you cut that out listen
she [ __ ] sucks but anyway I tolerate
him so I saw him and he's walking up the
steps and I'm you know I'm [ __ ]
flipping out and I see my friend that I
haven't seen in so long pandemic [ __ ]
put a [ __ ] [ __ ] in a lot of people's
uh friendships I only met him on Zoom oh
really because of the goddamn pandemic
he's the best and so I see him and I'm
like Duncan you know he's 18 rows ahead
of me going out and then he says that
thing that a lot of celebrities do that
I'm sure I do too he just gets a touch
rigid I'm like I'm not listen to that
fan yeah I'm leaving okay yeah and then
I'm like oh [ __ ] I get it I'm like how
do I I'm like Duncan it's already fear
but he's like and we just crying and
hugging each other oh it's the best why
was he crying
[Laughter]
that's my favorite one
um
yeah you gotta you're not getting buried
in a Jewish cemetery with that tattoo
huh are you getting cremated or buried I
don't care I'll let my friends do
whatever they want it's for the living
my uh first cousin's a funeral director
and a mortician yeah and I always had
the idea that like whenever I pass to
have him fly in and take control of my
body and like just do a bunch of [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] with it oh yeah have some fun
we'll have some fun with it right and
then I thought I can't wait like uh plus
like so then I thought that I would go
to uh like terminal Wards like hospices
and like walk around until maybe
somebody recognized me and like it got
stoked then sit down with them and be
like hey you know like is it a bummer
situation that you're in here you know
but like
what do you think
I got this cousin you can fly in you
know and like in a couple weeks no no no
no no no make you make you live beyond
no yeah like like my like legs in a
couple weeks like when you know like
when when it's inevitable when it's
finished my cousin can fly in and he can
embalm you and stuff and then you know
we could like strap you to a rocket
I think it'd be cool it was it was
I told the idea to my dad and he was
like terribly offended by it like uh put
it on Comedy Central or something yeah I
mean like if you like if like some
weekend you want to do like weekend at
Bernie he's for real yeah yeah exactly
how fun would that be my comedian
friends okay as long as my parents okay
with it uh go nuts you guys have some
fun you know I don't have any lines
right [ __ ] do it God why can't I
remember I brought up Duncan Trussell
I'm gonna [ __ ] kill me and then when
like so maybe like I die my cousin flies
in him bombs me straps me to a rocket I
get to do all this cool stuff and then
when we're done with that then uh like
dismember me and my idea used to be like
didn't take apart my my skeleton and and
I for all my best buddies
well yeah like make like uh like a like
a bowl to so my Bros can smoke weed out
of my bones like depending on like how
good of a bro you are the bigger the
bone you get oh yeah
I
got a good haul on a skull it's a
terrible well you gotta die like this
wow you gotta do it on the back
properly on the table light it out of
the mouth uh yeah yeah yeah for sure
interesting interesting
I gave you one last shot to remember why
we brought up here for some [ __ ]
reason and I sidetracked my goddamn self
saying
what would you Sidetrack yourself saying
saying oh I saw him actually at that
concert yeah but why would you bring him
up for a reason it was before Kevin
spoon at the [ __ ] we were talking about
right before Kevin Smith right before we
talked about that I was like oh Duncan
oh the pandemic was ruined a lot of
friendships that was part of the aside
uh
Comedy Store buddies that would be
faster
I don't know okay I wish we had a real
podcasts were real so we could actually
just rewind this
luckily it doesn't matter you're gonna
remember it yeah for sure it doesn't
matter I don't think there's one
listener who's like I don't care about
that he's gonna be a dumb story anywhere
what was that a story there's nothing
there was some reason I brought him up
there's not one listener that gives a
[ __ ] but I think there are a lot of
listeners who care a lot about us it's
not just about after you [ __ ] [ __ ] it
turn it over it's also but just day to
day you're walking around all day dude
you and I are on the same page because
on the side it says Stevo's butt wipes
for your butthole we're made to help
even the gnarliest ass become clean
enough to eat from with these amazing
flushable butt wipes you can enjoy a
perfectly clean poop shoot yeah dude
this is all you need if you go to
Glastonbury Music Festival that's all
you need that's your showers Stephen's
butt wipes for your butthole well they
work for underarms now with underarm
power too yeah dude
um so so uh R.A shaffir Jew
stand-up comedy special first one in
five years on YouTube on YouTube right
now where was it recorded recorded the
roulette theater in uh Brooklyn New York
the home of the Jews nice okay yeah do
you have a lot of Jews in the audience a
few yeah I would do there'll be some of
those people that'll get mad but most
Jews will be like this is interesting
and funny okay I can guys say Jews can I
say Jews depends how hard you hit the J
are there any
is there any Scientology comedians who
left the church and could make a special
called Scientologist yeah May let's see
who else who was Bobby Lee was dating a
Scientologist for a while oh yeah ramini
he never dated her but she is one yeah
yeah
she was born into it she was so well put
together Tom Cruise gets him to stand up
and just they were trying to get to you
yeah exactly oh he would dominate
instantly
I worked hard at this
idioms but I'm crushing yeah
ah [ __ ] we lost the camera that's okay
because I gotta I I gotta I gotta go
they're texting me to set the video up
okay what are we promoting other than
your special I have a podcast called uh
Ari shaffer's Cafe and I'm starting a
new podcast
called uh you be tripping it's a travel
podcast nice I'd love to have you on
that cool I'm just telling about some
fun places I've Been Everywhere I know
not everywhere but uh I have places
where you left some places right yeah I
mean yeah I've been to like 58
countries I saw you in a 58 yeah 58
that's [ __ ] great I'm up to like 40.
that's great nice he's been to like 55.
really yeah I saw Steve at an airport
once in Vancouver cut it or not and uh I
was like you like Hannah like yeah these
chicks [ __ ] yeah
dude yeah I'm not I'm not doing this cut
it cutting stuff
all right dude what do you have two
tonight uh I'm gonna go to uh some more
skank fish [ __ ] okay
um I'm the president of skank Fest this
is me and Shane ran from the president
vice president yeah
um cool it brings my heart that you're
gonna miss my show cause uh it's [ __ ]
when you come to New York not as hell uh
I got a show in New York town hall
theater in uh December
okay I think I'm traveling then but if
yeah if it's but thanks for letting me
get the word out about my show in New
York John Hall's a great theater yeah
yeah I'm super strong for it well hey
dude [ __ ] you're a good support yeah
dude good to meet you you're a good
sport yeah so he is he's not not gonna
lie I had absolute like uh reservations
okay is it a good idea to have Ari on
the emotions gone from all those things
is that gonna hurt me
I said you know what it said like I just
want to ask him like uh I said um first
question like is how much [ __ ] am I
gonna catch for having you on I was like
that's interesting that just starts off
on an interesting but it's funny to me
that the guy who will snort Wasabi is
gonna go is this gonna hurt me I'm very
sensitive I'm very very sensitive but
dude like I also want to thank you for
being supportive of me doing stand up
for you know like uh or some people not
I mean there's not not too many but uh
yeah but yeah there's been some of that
and I love it welcome it's like we're
all doing the same [ __ ] man we're all
just trying to write a good dick joke
and you have your own style with it too
yeah I definitely have my own style on
um on uh in my new book I just put out a
new book and you can't even read
I got two bucks what yeah
um that I I describe two types of people
in my book I said they're Marc maron's
and they're Joe Rogan's just so
supportive and I'll leave it at that
like like Mark Maron when like had me on
to promote my first special
I went on on the mark maritz podcast and
he and he were sitting he was like Hey
you know like
I just like when I found out you're
doing stand-up I was just like you know
he's like I'm kind of protective of the
art I was just you know like and I just
remember thinking like why is he saying
this to me like why am I here you know
like and that's just you know
he's also supportive but he's also but
bless his heart he's coming that's just
that's an interesting but but my my take
on it by that whole vibe you know people
who are protective of stand up and don't
want others coming in is that they're
operating with a mentality of scarcity
like it like if steambo comes into stand
up and is successful then there's going
to be less food on the table for them
but that's not true there's so much food
right and but but it's this this this
this this mentality of scarcity and then
there's Joe Rogan has a very distinct
mentality of abundance he he says he
says he wants his [ __ ] mailman to
dude
[Music]
I'm the best at this [ __ ] you guys I
mastered this then everyone's like sweet
there's a a way to if you this is an old
Jewish thing there when I was little
they're like treat knowledge or like
help them fill them out as a candle your
candle's out if I light your candle with
my candle my candle doesn't go out right
my candle is the exact same that's great
I like that yeah and uh so yeah I
appreciate you and your your attitude of
abundance yeah more funny [ __ ] in the
world yeah exactly
I like funny [ __ ] I want there to be
more funny [ __ ] in the world he's like
you're so supportive yeah Super Rad
hinge Cliff too because uh yeah yeah all
right man well [ __ ] thank you for for
coming on us I'm sure we're glad we did
this it's good to see you it's been a
long time yeah I threw up in a [ __ ]
jackass show Once I was laughing so hard
oh nice
show like the [ __ ] dick was way too
far down my throat
um
right on oh yeah dude yep so in
conclusion I can say uh genuinely and
honestly I'm really glad that we did
that episode with Ari if I had any
reservations about his bad behavior
um I enjoyed talking to him I liked him
I mean I had met him before he was
always really cool I really like him a
lot more after the podcast and God am I
impressed by that special I'm not just
saying that dude check out Jew on
YouTube man it is really
unbelievable how impressive that is and
you know
I love you I love you
I'm also really really happy with what's
going on on my tour it's uh
like I feel like I'm
blowing up yeah dude so thanks everybody